dans les rues de new york vous aurez du
mal à trouver des supporters de donald
trump ou en tout cas des personnes qui
se revendique en tant que tel il ya bien
des gens qui arborent des autocollants à
l'effigié de joe biden par exemple mais
personne ne porte cette fameuse
casquette rouge mec america goasguen un
des symboles de ralliement des
supporters de donald trump et lorsque
certains osent cet accoutrement dans les
rues de la ville il peut leur arriver
quelques problèmes c'est en tout cas
l'histoire qui est arrivé à cet homme
dans les rues new york il ya maintenant
plusieurs semaines
un homme affirme avoir été frappée à new
york parce qu'il portait une casquette
michael meurer cas great games il ya
moins de dix jours des supporters de
donald trump se sont donné rendez vous à
quelques mètres d'ici à times square et
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ils ont
rapidement été rejoints par des
contre-manifestants ce qui a provoqué
des violences affrontements en plein
coeur de la ville
[Applaudissements]
d'où cette question est ce qu'il est
dangereux aujourd'hui à new york de
porter un symbole de ralliement à donald
trump
on a posé la question à un certain
nombre de new york m il ne faut pas
faire ça ce serait chercher le conflit
cherché la confrontation
franchement je ne le conseille pas
surtout vu le cul massey tamise on n'est
jamais trop prudent
on est des gens feront des gens honnêtes
il dit ce qu'on a sur le coeur donc ce
genre de chose ne me surprend pas je
leur demanderai d'abord pourquoi ils
soutiennent trump c'est un homme qui
distille la haine comme vous le savez ce
supermarché dans n'a pas l'air mais il
illustre à lui seul les tensions qui
peuvent exister entre les électeurs du
camp byden éduquant trump il ya quelques
jours le gérant de ce magasin on est à
l'ong island à une centaine de
kilomètres de manhattan à proposer à ses
clients une remise de 20% mais une
remise qui ne s'applique uniquement pour
les supporters de donald trump lorsqu'il
a publié cette annonce sur les réseaux
sociaux de son établissement
délibérément de réactions notamment de
la part de certains démocrates qui ont
appelé au boycott de ce supermarché on a
été boycottée par la gauche
n'achetez pas ici etc mais on a aussi
des partisans de trump qui sont venus
nous soutenir
ils ne sont même pas venus pour les
promotions mais juste pour nous apporter
leur soutien nous sommes dans un pays
libre
il s'agit de ma liberté d'expression et
personne ne me privera de ce droit face
à tant de réactions
le propriétaire a donc décidé
d'appliquer cette réduction également
pour ceux qui se revendiquent comme des
supporters de joe biden alors qu'en
pensent les clients ou encore les
propriétaires des autres établissements
qui se trouve à côté on était leur poser
la question personnellement moi je
n'aurais pas fait ça je gère mes
magasins tout le monde a ses propres
convictions ses propres opinions
politiques
je n'aurais pas fait ça il veut tout
trump et pourquoi pas les grosses
entreprises donnent de l'argent aux
candidats
pourquoi n'aurait-il pas le droit il
faut bien voter pour quelqu'un je ne
vois pas le problème
il est donc devenu très difficile
d'afficher sa préférence sans risquer un
retour de bâton et il ne s'agit pas
uniquement des supporters de donald
trump
cette femme s'est également retrouvée
sous le feu des critiques pour avoir
réalisé cette vidéo sur tik tok où elle
affirme seulement que son père
républicain de toujours a décidé de
voter pour joe biden cette année afin de
faire plaisir à ses filles
un message qui se voulait inspirant et
qui a finalement provoqué beaucoup de
réactions agressives
finalement ces exemples illustrent à
quel point les clivages sont désormais
ancré dans la population américaine peu
importe qui remportera le scrutin cette
année il y aura de toute façon plusieurs
paires dans le dialogue et la tolérance
dans les débats politiques par exemple